Xavier yakovelli bonsoir merci aussi à
vous d'avoir accepté de débattre avec
Olivier fort qui est notre invité ce
soir auditions publiques vous êtes
sénateur renaissance des Hauts-de-Seine
vous allez peut-être vouloir revenir sur
le mouvement contre la réforme des
retraites et les manifestations oui mais
j'aimerais poser une première question
si vous le permettez à Monsieur le
Député bonjour déjà bonsoir pardon sur
un sujet qui me tient particulièrement à
cœur et je pense qu'on peut trouver une
majorité de projets sur ce sujet c'est
le SLU le service national universel
depuis 2019 le président de la
République avait déjà porté en 2017 un
sujet pour que les jeunes soient les
bâtisseurs d'une nation plus forte plus
juste plus écologiste et ça pour le coup
je pense que tout le monde partage ce
sujet et puis à sa demande la Ministre
en charge justement de la jeunesse et du
s&u madame elaery apporter cette mission
de généralisation voire même c'est un
des une des options de l'obligation du
s&u avec un séjour de cohésion de 12
jours vous connaissez le principe 12
jours qui s'appuie sur l'éducation
nationale l'éducation populaire et les
corps en uniforme et puis un séjour de
mission d'intérêt général sur la base du
volontariat et un autre séjour qui
pourrait être un engagement dans le
service civique depuis 2019 depuis sa
création c'est 50000 jeunes qui ont fait
qui ont pu bénéficier de ce dispositif
sur la base du volontariat dans votre
département c'est 1300 un peu plus de
1300 je crois qui ont qui en ont
bénéficié et donc je trouve que ce
projet c'est un projet structurant pour
notre nation pour notre jeunesse et donc
moi j'aimerais avoir votre opinion sur
sur la question du s&u et son obligation
surtout bon moi je suis contre
l'obligation et surtout je suis contre
un projet qui est pour l'instant très
mal ficel et je suis pour caractère
volontaire et s'il y a des gens qui
veulent s'inscrire dans ce projet qui
est souvent qui permet de réaliser de
beaux projets avec mon associatif etc
donc ça très bien
sur l'obligation pour moi c'est un sujet
parce que surtout que là les 15 jours
qui sont proposés honnêtement on est
dans la grande improvisation avec un
coût qui va être un coup exorbitant par
rapport à ce qu'il va me permettre la
cohésion en 15 jours c'est une
gigantesque blague c'est pas 15 jours
qui vont permettre le brassage social
qu'on a connu à d'autres époques avec le
service national qui est là à l'époque
était réservé aux hommes mais donc
d'accord pour envisager en fait
l'extension de ce qui existe aujourd'hui
et faire en sorte qu'il y ait plus de
jeunes qui puissent accéder au
volontariat ça très bien mais national
universel où on viendrait prendre 15
jours d'études pour faire des séjours
dans la forêt et faire de l'accrobranche
franchement je suis pas sûr que ce soit
très utile c'est quoi valeur de la
République c'est pas forcément des de
l'accrobranche je pense que vous êtes
attaché comme nous aux valeurs de la
République au gestes de premiers secours
de créer de formater un peu des citoyens
de demain moi je trouve qu'au contraire
c'est très bien bah oui mais donc ne
réduisez pas ne rédigez pas seulement à
des parcours dans la forêt et de
l'accrobranche on parle de plusieurs
milliards pour le SNU alors qu'on
cherche des milliards pour la sécu en
fait et là je me dis en fait on va
inventer un truc qui va servir à pas
grand chose pour alors qu'on nous
explique que il nous faut trouver les
2019 non mais là je parle voté je parle
du SNU qui est envisagé par le
gouvernement et qui lui serait non pas
sur la base du volontariat mais sur la
base de l'obligation pour toutes et pour
tous la première partie donc c'est qu'un
fameux 15 jours c'est c'est eux qui
coûte de l'argent en plus et donc pas
grand chose
15 jours de cohésion enfin vous quand je
parle d'accrobranche en fait c'est à
dire que c'est ce qu'on connaît en
entreprise on va mettre les gens enfin
du saut à l'élastique ensemble ils vont
être bon ils vont s'amuser pendant 15
jours sur le temps scolaire alors qu'on
a déjà tant de difficulté que le système
scolaire on va
franchement moi je préférerais que ce
soit pendant l'année scolaire toute
l'année que les cours d'instruction
civique soient renforcées je préférerais
que on est là plus enseignant qu'on
puisse perdre qu'on puisse recruter
grâce aux milliards
et là vous aurez peut-être vraiment que
ça plus efficace et qui sera continue et
non pas simplement pour qu'un jour de
balade je comprends bien monsieur le
député effectivement que donc vous êtes
contre le SNU ce beau projet structurant
mais obligatoire mais est-ce que est-ce
que je peux vous croire en fait bah oui
est-ce que est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
aujourd'hui l'incohérence incarnée
quand je vois que vous avez voté la
réforme Touraine et que vous voulez
maintenant voter enfin vous avez voté
contre la la réforme des retraites quand
vous avez
défendu le 49-3 sous le gouvernement
Hollande et que maintenant vous le
combattez et vous voulez même le sortir
de la Constitution quand vous voulez
abroger la loi travail alors même que
vous l'avez voté en tant que député et
président de groupe lorsque vous avez
signé une tribune que j'aurais pu signer
avec vous sur la laïcité et que vous
défilez bras dessus bras dessous avec
ceux qui laissent à penser que ceux qui
ont vécu Charlie il avait peut-être bien
cherché ou ceux qui aujourd'hui
pardonnez-moi ou qui pardonnez-moi mais
qui disent que la laïcité est un vrai
problème c'est pas Grosso monsieur
je pense sincèrement que vous êtes un
cas vous êtes un cas vous êtes un cas
unique en France en fait vous êtes le
seul hollandais mélenchoniste bien sûr
alors d'abord on va essayer de pas se
traiter de nom d'oiseaux parce que si
apparemment c'est pas un gros mot pour
vous vous pourrez derrière votre
parcours et il n'y a pas de souci assez
édifiant donc j'en en parlerai même il
est très cohérent surtout contrairement
à vous par ailleurs je vois pas du tout
le rapport que vous mettez entre ce que
j'ai pu voter avec la loi Touraine et ce
qu'est cette réforme aujourd'hui aucun
rapport la loi Touraine vous devez vous
en souvenir c'était une loi qui permette
en fait de protéger les carrières
longues qui permettait aussi de mettre
de faire en sorte qu'il y ait des gens
qui soient pour les métiers pénibles en
situation de partir plutôt ce qu'on a
fait et on a recréé des critères de
pénibilité à la demande d'ailleurs des
organisations syndicales
de
pénibilités
entre le
ça va pas en faire une vérité donc c'est
pas la peine de continuer c'est bien
vous avez des éléments de langage mais
si vous voulez qu'on parle du fond
parlant du fond ce sera mieux pour tout
le monde et n'essayez pas donc
l'accusation d'un cohérence vous la
refusez donc vous ne voulez vous voulez
pas Roger la loi travail que vous avez
voté d'accord donc ça c'est de la
cohérence mais je l'ai pas voté vous
n'avez pas voté la loi travail
absolument pas la loi travail
vous l'avez pas voté bah écoutez
j'invite les auditeurs à regarder sur le
compte-rendu de vous n'avez pas voté pas
très difficile à ça allez passer par 49
3 non attendez donc vous n'avez pas voté
vous n'avez pas voté la confiance en
gouvernement sur le 49-3 vous n'avez pas
défendu sur les plateaux
là vous mélangez tout vous êtes en train
de tout mélanger
l'histoire donc essayez d'être cohérent
vous-même quand vous essayez de
m'accuser vous venez avec des dossiers
qui sont des dossiers construits pour
l'instant c'est pas construit donc vous
n'êtes que vous reviendrez la prochaine
fois et vous viendrez avec une
documentation en montrant ce que j'ai
fait pas fait etc en l'occurrence et sur
la laïcité j'ai pas changé d'avis non
plus donc vous avez signé un accord
aujourd'hui avec un parti politique qui
remet en cause et qui dit même que la
laïcité est un problème n'importe quoi
personne ne dit que la laïcité est un
problème
y compris pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais
quand vous étiez pas spécialiste vous
deviez vous en souvenir Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et on était aussi et il était
celui qui donnait des cours de laïcité à
tout le monde vous devriez quand même
avoir
et ce que je vous dis c'est que moi je
ne partage pas il y a des gens enfin
insoumises qui ont parfois eu un mot que
je Conan je n'ai pas participé à cette
manifestation à laquelle vous faites
référence à laquelle participait les
communistes les écologistes et beaucoup
de monde en réalité est-ce que ça en
fait des gens qui sont contre la laïcité
non ça venait à la suite d'une à
l'attentat contre une mosquée et donc
avec considéré que ça permet ça devait
passer par-dessus tout le reste moi j'ai
conseillé de passer pas par dessus tout
le reste c'était une appréciation
différente mais ça ne fait pas de ces
gens-là des anti républicains comme vous
avez tendance à vouloir maintenant
l'affirmer mais soyez cohérent vous et
continuez à vous battre contre l'extrême
droite parce que ce que je vois que vous
faites aujourd'hui si vous êtes en train
de dédiaboliser l'extrême droite pour
essayer de diaboliser la gauche vous
devriez avoir honte tout seul mais
monsieur le député rappelez-vous juste
que nous nous avons appelé à voter pour
les candidats du Parti socialiste quand
ils étaient opposés au rassemblement
national que vous ne faites pas
aujourd'hui avec votre candidate
dissidente qui est vous vous préférez
voter pour l'extrême gauche celle qui
est antivax celle qui a eu des positions
sur Israël qui sont indignes de
gauche pardonnez-moi mais il y a aussi
un vrai sujet mais c'est pas c'est fou
attendez monsieur fort vous avez dit
tout à l'heure sur le plateau mais c'est
pas moi qui l'a inventé vous avez dit
sur le plateau que vous souteniez vous
souteniez effectivement la candidature
de l'année française
c'est quand même essayons d'être là
aussi si vous voulez être dans la vérité
est-ce qu'elle est antivax elle est prof
de science et technologique elle est
pour la vaccination elle était contre le
passe sanitaire c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose c'est un problème de liberté
publique où elle est non avec le premier
point sur la question de l'antisémitisme
elle est elle a été soutenir une
proposition de résolution du Parti
communiste qui va d'ailleurs être
discussion prochainement à l'Assemblée
est-ce que les communistes sont
antisémites est-ce que ils ont repris
une accusation que vous pouvez ne pas
partager et de dire
pardonnez-moi mais pardonnez-moi c'est
une attaque claire que je vous montre
Israël et je ne suis pas sûr aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous condamnez cette
proposition de résolution je pense que
depuis tout à l'heure vous parlez est-ce
que c'est je voudrais pardonnez-moi mais
il y a une question de la sécurité vous
avez tenu des propos à chardonnez-moi
vous avez vous montrer des photos aucune
vous avez porté des accusations très
graves sur la police pardonnez-moi vous
avez une nouvelle doctrine vous voulez
pas qu'on vous a plu
j'ai à l'autre pour éviter qu'on vous
répondez la nouvelle doctrine d'Olivier
fort et du Parti socialiste attention
on ne comprend plus rien la nouvelle
doctrine
et j'espère que vous ne serez jamais
ministre de l'intérieur c'est de faire
en sorte que lorsqu'il y a des
manifestations il ne faut surtout pas
mettre de force de l'ordre c'est
exactement ce que vous avez dit et vous
avez porté des accusations très
complotistes pardonnez-moi sur le fait
même que le gouvernement était à
l'initiative du chaos que qui se sont
des qui sont déroulés hier effectivement
ce sont des grands accusations et et
appréciation du fait que ça pourrait
être du complotisme de dire que le
gouvernement effectivement préfère le
chaos
c'est la dernière que la dernière
révolutionnaire
heureux et j'espère que vous aurez un
bon point mais la réalité c'est que la
démocratie
prise de position écoutez on va
s'arrêter là
merci merci à tous les deux merci si je
puis dire si je puis dire sur le fond
mais malheureusement c'est pas possible
vous pouvez peut-être répondre pour
soutenir nos forces de l'ordre si vous
voulez on a déjà vu on a déjà eu ce
débat je le fais